the first thing that goes through your
mind when you you know you seal game
four you close it out on the road and
you realize you made nuggets history
first trip to the NBA finals what are
you thinking
no it's just just I think it's just like
you happy to put it to moan again you
you'll be you'll be really really good
team you will think about except the
first game every game was so close and
every every team could want it and um we
will just find a way to win the game
especially we were down 15 and to come
back and and win the game
you know it was just here probably
happiness you know
I think that's that's the emotions
Nicola
um you had talked the other day about
saying you weren't scared but you were
worried about LeBron James being on the
other side what were you thinking as
LeBron had that monster first half
monster game and also what did it mean
to you to win Western Conference Finals
MVP what what does that feel like
compared to winning your two mpps
I mean just because I mean we know what
is this LeBron capable and he showed us
what he's capable in the first half
he was just dominating the game
um but we found a way that make him
take tough shots or just not easy layups
or just not open shots in the second
half I think
he was the lineup for 13 in the first
half right
and then he was he was three four
twelves in a second so I think we did a
good job in the second half
but to be honest this is just a
I don't know I don't think about MVP
Mbps anymore and I think it's a people
are just
um
mean and saying that impede shouldn't
want it I think she should he should
want it I think he was a he was playing
uh
if you watch it extremely extremely
tough basketball through whole season
and uh
I don't want to say it player doesn't
mean in that but he he was he was really
amazing in 82 games or whoever how many
games he played
to the left over here Nicola I know you
still have work to do but who are you
most proud of most happy for In This
Moment
phew I don't know you know I I I'm gonna
say I'm gonna say Jamal uh just because
he was uh like like you said he was
injured he was uh getting through tough
period
he thought he didn't they're gonna trade
him
um and then he he that the way how he's
leading Us and how he's uh controlling
the game and uh
making shots playing like even last year
this year is last year's he's he's
playing he's playing he's playing really
well you know so
I think I think I'm so happy for Jamal
just to proving that he is worth and his
uh his uh he's a special player in this
league
Nicola how much more special does
opportunity uh how much more special is
this opportunity knowing that you guys
have held your kind of same core
together and built this the right way
for you and built this brand of
basketball and built this culture
altogether
I decided I started in uh on the on the
court it's really from The Spark engine
to the family cranky I think it's
something that we really build and
really we really like I was drafted by
nuggets uh
Jamal was drafted by now it's Michael's
dress with my nuggets you know ads here
a little bit long a little a little
while right now so we and we we get a
great great uh pieces in in Bruce in uh
in Bruce and um and and kcp Jeff and
Jeff who is a really good veteran uh
CB who is in a rotation I'm to be honest
I don't want to see that but little
everybody not just not just players in
in in training and coaching staff
it's something that
Jordan left a bunch of bunch of guys
left but uh I think that shows that
shows too that we are doing something
good you know the people are leaving
from this organization to to better
spots and I'm happy for everybody so I
think we are doing something something
nice
front row here okay Nicola the only
break you got was the first couple
minutes of the second quarter how are
you feeling after playing 45 minutes and
and was there any point in the fourth
quarter where you got a little tired or
I think I think that's why players are
so nice and so so interesting because
you don't care about how tired you are
you don't care about minutes your files
shots percentage this and that you know
you just you just want to win a game and
you're trying to win the game
like sometimes you feel today's women
have been a defense you know sometimes
you know
it's it's such a great period of of year
for basketball and just you can win it
in every kind of possible way you know
on the right LeBron mentioned there were
several shots you hit this series that
you just had he said he literally took
his hat off so you just have to tip your
cap uh obviously the The Late Three like
250 left off balance uh you know
somebody all over you how are you so
comfortable taking those shots and you
know what are you feeling if that thing
leaves your hand
I mean
what's up I'm gonna take that's my
signature shot
I'm joking and um
I don't know in that situation you're
just trying to shoot and just trying to
score I think that to be honest that's
kind of the easier shot because you need
to shoot it you don't you I was I was
wide open in one possession and I was
just driving and LeBron took a charge uh
in if it's like more seconds I will
shoot it so I think it's so easy to
shoot when you know you gotta shoot it
so you just find a way to shoot it and
uh being off of balance I'm off balance
my whole life so that's kind of
normal for me
front row mark
you've told us many times that you never
expected to be in the NBA what's it mean
to a guy who never expected to be here
to have a chance to win a championship
in the NBA
um
yeah I think I'm sorry I'm really happy
for the guys and for the organization
and just how how we we fight through I
remember the days when nobody was in
like you could you could hear you could
hear the the bounce
the ball bouncing on the floor and then
there is no no fast and we have a
sellout every every other night so just
for the organization that was just for
people just for coach for for all the
players that everybody adopted doubt and
um you know I think I'm just happy and
means a lot for for me for the
collective that we have
um I can there's a I know you deleted
social media a long time ago we've
everybody digs up old tweets there's one
where you were saying is anyone down for
a pickup basketball game back in 2011
um first part is just so why did you
delete social media and two is how are
you different from that kid back in 2011
asking for a pickup game
you know how hard is to find a pickle
Bay right now in in especially in my
hometown like I remember the days when
you can just go outside in five o'clock
afternoon and you if you lose that one
one pickup game you can basically go
home and now it's really hard to find a
to find a uh like six guys who can
because we play three on three it's not
a 505. uh
so that didn't change so if anybody
wants to go play pickup yeah they can
call me
just because to be honest I follow the
guys who are like playing this playing
professionally right now that's 3x3 uh
tournament in their Serbian guys are
really really good in that and I think
they're I think I remember back in days
at how I played it and I think
maybe the talent that the the the
engineer from upstairs gave me it's from
from playing basket to playing three on
three two and why I deleted social media
I think it's a waste of time
Nicola uh you said just now that you
think you might be happiest for Jamal uh
could you sort of take us through that
last play of the game as as LeBron
drives and sort of how important it was
that Jamal was able to get his hands in
there and help like even like we were so
connected everybody like we knew we knew
that we're not gonna switch uh we know
we're gonna they're gonna open him up
somehow we know we we didn't want to
switch and we we knew like as soon as
the mile ago I was kind of inching in
for for rui I know that ad was in a
corner so everything is everything was
so connected and um it was it was great
question right here
hi I don't know if you know him very
well another Djokovic you guys are the
two serving stars in sports he's going
to have one girls coming you're going to
have this big uh finals to play are you
going to talk to you know to each other
about this or you don't you don't have
that type of conversation I don't have
his number to be honest but he is the
guy who represents Serbia in a much
bigger scene and much he's a Serbian
Amber said Ambassador and he's really
Idol to the kids in Serbia and uh not
just on the court and the things that
his foundation is doing uh he's the guy
who can you can look up uh you I want to
be like him you know so he is doing
something great for for uh for kids for
Serbia for everything so
we are not we are not gonna we cannot be
compared